guys this video is made possible by
Monday kama team management platform
creating more efficient and intuitive
ways to manage teams and entire
operations sport the show and try Monday
comm through the link below the worlds
has an eerie fascination with serial
killers whether it's hearing tales of
men who process their victims through
meat grinders in order to feed the
remains to future victims or stories of
strange fetishes and incomprehensible
desires to commit atrocities upon
corpses people can't help but be
intrigued the dark side of the human
psyche has been featured on screens big
and small for decades and there is
something bum deny oblique captivating
about true crime it just doesn't let you
look away today we're used to the idea
of criminal profiling it's the science
of looking at a crime and its victims in
order to understand everything we can
about its perpetrators it's easy to
forget the modern criminology is a
relatively new science pioneered by one
man who joins the Federal Bureau of
Investigation in 1970 although he first
started out in Swat and later became a
hostage negotiator it was when John E
Douglas finally ended up in the
classroom at Quantico that he found his
life's calling he spent much of his
career investigating some of the most
violent and dangerous criminals who have
ever stalked and preyed upon the
innocence Douglass logged years of work
interviewing dangerous men trying to
uncoil just what made them tick you may
not recognize his name that you
certainly recognize the characters that
have been based on him and the shows
that have been inspired by his life his
story has been the inspiration for the
Silence of the Lambs as well as the show
Criminal Minds a fictionalized version
of him was portrayed in Netflix's mind
Hunter Douglas really did sit down with
some of the most notorious serial
killers and violent offenders that the
country has ever seen using what he
learned from them to build up the
groundwork for the science of criminal
profiling unsurprisingly spending years
in the midst of psychotic killers is a
health hazard
as you're going to find out in today's
bio graphics Douglas he was fortunate
enough to escape with his life
[Music]
Douglas wrote the book minds hunter
inside the FBI's elite serial crime unit
about his experiences in the early days
of behavioral analysis the Netflix
series of nearly the same name took
liberties with the story as his life was
shaped into the character of Holden Ford
while there was a bit of creative
license taken with the details there was
a lot of truth in the show - starting
with his motives for deciding to
interview serial killers in the first
place
now it's important to note that the FBI
already had a behavioral sciences unit
before Douglas came onto the scene it
was established in 1971 and law
enforcement already knew how valuable
psychology could be in tracking down
criminals but here's the thing
it wasn't systemized there was no manual
no set of classifications no definitions
no framework to base assessments on when
Douglas transferred there in 1977 to
begin teaching hostage negotiation and
applied criminal psychology the
department was still new and well so was
Douglas on paper he looked great he was
going into the classroom with a few
years of military service behind him and
seven years as a field agents under his
belt
but he was only 32 years old and it's
seen how classrooms worked Quantico
instructors needed to be at the top of
their game because sometimes they were
teaching the details of a case to agents
and officers it would actually worked
that a very case and those agents they
didn't hesitate to challenge an
instructor if they said something even
slightly wrong Douglass realized that
the fastest way to learn cases and
criminals was to go right to the source
he needed to build up some serious
credibility so he started talking to
some of the nation's most infamous
criminals Douglass began setting up
interviews with some of the most
prolific serial offenders of his time
and during that era well there were
plenty of men available to him the 1970s
80s and 90s would become known as a
golden age of serial killers with more
than 80% of the 20th century serials
cropping up during those three decades
criminologists now believed the serial
phenomenon had something to do with the
coming of age of men who had been raised
in the aftermath of world war ii and
events that left broken families and
broken people to raise their children
Ted Bundy Charles Manson John Wayne Gacy
ed Kemper
spec david berkowitz the list is
certainly a long one and it keeps going
far past the headliners for the public
at large each name was associated with a
terrorised community or a series of
gruesome crimes for John Douglas each
name was another corrupted mind to probe
and explore Douglass found that what he
was learning from some of the most
deviant minds the bureau had ever
crossed paths with was something that
could be applied to all violent crimes
and not just murders at first he said he
started conducting interviews for
survival but it wasn't long before he
realized the work would allow him to
provide some valuable insights into
future investigations of course not
everyone agreed with him or his methods
in fact his biggest detractor was the
FBI Douglass's investigations into the
criminal mind has been invaluable but at
the time he was actively conducting
interviews the powers that be at the FBI
didn't see it that way at all the FBI
was concerned among other things about
bureaucracy and the chain of command
Douglass was the one out in the field
traveling the country interviewing
serial killers and getting to know the
local officers who were actually on the
front lines of all these cases when
everyday officers need its help on open
investigations many local officers
started calling him directly instead of
jumping through the hoops of a more
official FBI communication channel
Douglass never wanted to turn anyone
away for bureaucratic reasons because he
knew that red tape was likely to
discourage agents that he could advise
quickly rather than scolds officers or
agents for coming straight to him it
helped them develop a profile or advise
on what information should be released
to the media
sometimes Douglass felt that conflict
very acutely in some of the most
unlikely places one of the first big
cases that the young behavioral science
unit consulted on was the case Netflix's
mind hunter presents on center stage and
that's the Atlanta child murders the
case was real and the killing spree
began with the 1979 murders of a 13 year
old Alfred Evans and a 14 year old
Edward Hope Smith originally thought to
be just another drug-related killing it
wasn't until somewhere around 19 more
children either disappeared or
turned up dead that law enforcement
began to connect them finally seeing
what the community had been trying to
tell them all along and that's that
there was a killer on the loose
Douglass went to Atlanta in 1981 walking
the woods where bodies had been found
and reviewing files he wasn't exactly
welcomed with open arms though after
sitting down for an FBI sanctioned
interview with People magazine during
what she said he was certain they were
looking for a killer who was black he
suddenly found himself working with a
field office that was less than thrilled
with the effects they believed his
comments were going to have the entire
situation was a powder keg the community
had already organized an initiative
called stop which they did hoping to
convince the Atlanta Police Department
view the killings as connected but an
undercurrent of racism and accusations
that some of the local cops were
card-carrying members of the Ku Klux
Klan overshadowed any earnest efforts
douglass was trying to make at the time
the black community was certain the KKK
was responsible and the idea that a
white FBI agent sat down and publicly
declared that the killer was black just
didn't sit well with many and gave the
impression that law enforcement wasn't
entirely on the side of impartial
justice Douglass's comments just looked
bad
there was a sentiment that may have been
somewhat halves waged had the FBI agents
in the Atlanta field office been
introduced to the media especially
Special Agent in Charge John Glover who
was the first black agents leader field
office there were no introductions and
instead Douglass was told repeatedly
that he was on the verge of starting a
race war Douglass found himself fighting
an uphill battle to get anyone to listen
to his ideas including applying his
profile to the attendees at the Frank
Sinatra and Sammy Davis jr. benefit
concert which was organized help fund
the city's massive manhunt hit hoped to
get agents on board with his case theory
on vetting all attendees at the concert
which would have eliminated women and
suspects without car before moving on to
racial filters Douglass hopes that
process would give them a pool of
suspects to investigate further but it
was never done
sadly it might have helped Wayne
Williams the man later arrested in
connection with at least some of the
murders not only fit the profile that
was at the concert
Douglas long maintains that Williams was
the right color for some of the cases
but he's also remained steadfast in his
belief that he wasn't the only killer
that was based on not just his
assessment of the
crimes but a pattern seen in the choice
of victims as for Williams he was
convicted of the murder of two adults
associated with the case but the murders
of the children have remained unsolved
the case was reopened in August of 2019
okay so just before we get into the rest
of today's video I want to take a really
quick moment to tell you about today's
sponsor Monday comm Monday comm is a
team management tool which is perfect
for teams of any size
maybe you're just you and another
freelancer friend working together well
maybe you've got thousands of people
working for you or maybe like me yes
somewhere in between your answer for me
closer to the smaller size than the
thousand sighs now if you're not a fan
of long meetings who is or you get lost
in Excel sheets and whiteboard
presentations then Monday comm is
perfect to you Monday comm have replaced
all of those with an intuitive and
empowering platform that is very popular
among non tech teams now I'm not a
particularly techie person myself and I
like the fact that the platform is easy
for everyone to use including myself
Monday comm currently works for tens of
thousands of teams and is trusted by
giant companies like Discovery Channel
we work Buber and anymore so empower
your team and make them feel like
they're part of something bigger with
Monday comm you can get started with a
free trial through the link in the
description below let's get back to
today's video
[Music]
what is the one thing that anyone
fascinated by true crime and psychology
would love to do a deep dive into that
would be the transcripts and recordings
of Douglass's interviews with people
like Charles Manson and at Kempe but is
the thing transcripts and tapes of most
of his interviews they don't exist but
of Douglass's work wasn't just in
figuring out the right questions to ask
it was figuring out how to get them to
answer and how to interpret the answers
given when he first began conducting his
interviews he brought along a tape
recorder but it wasn't long before he
realized that the recording was a huge
mistake and it was making his subject
suspicious of him
Douglas was already at a disadvantage
going in as a member of the law
enforcement system that had arrested
tried convicted and sentenced them he
represented the authority that ordered
them around every day and when he
recorded conversations or trying to
write them down
he found that two things happens his
subject screws suspicious that what they
were saying was going to be used against
them somehow and when he wrote they grew
angry and belligerent in order to get
them to talk Douglass knew he had to
create an environment that would
facilitate a dialogue and that meant he
had to skip a recording device he simply
had to rely on his memory there are a
few things he discovered were necessary
to getting the information that he
wanted and it started out before he even
set foot in a prison preparation was
essential and he would spend time going
through every aspect of the cases
associated with the person he was
speaking to police reports crime scene
photos autopsy details it was a grisly
amounts of information to sift through
but it would allow him to know when the
offender was being truthful and when
they were lying these criminals they
lied a lot and if he could call them out
on it it went a long way in establishing
a relationship that allowed him to
demonstrate how well he knew their case
or how closely had studied them to a
serial killer as flattering
after the memorization game most
everything else came down to comfort and
control but he learns that control is a
tricky thing there's a scene that
happens at least once per episode in
almost every police procedural law
enforcement goes into a room where a
suspect is being held and confronts them
there's a lot of anger some posturing a
lot of shouting and usually a plenty of
accusations this is the exact opposite
of the atmosphere Douglass knew
he needed to create he always stressed
that it wasn't an interrogation it was a
conversation conversations go both ways
and oftentimes that meant killers had
questions for him they asked about his
job his family and he answered them
truthfully by answering the questions
asked of him he could create the
illusion that they were the ones in
control they knew something about him
and it made them giddy over the years
Douglas built up a playbook of interview
techniques they outlined how important
the setup of the room wasn't stressed
that seating arrangements should be made
based on personality for example he gave
paranoid individuals the chance to be
seated so that they could always see a
door or a window and dominant
personalities like Charles Manson would
be given the chance to sit above him
looking down and well they usually took
it certain words like murder and killing
were never used Blaine was never
projected and discussed or judgment was
never shown he was always careful to
keep his body language and posture
relaxed neutral ins even likened it's
the sort of way one might act on a first
date there was never any negativity but
feigning empathy was sometimes a must
sympathy for the devil indeed in the end
it was often one simple thing that got
many of recent history's most notorious
serial killers to open up to him he
played to their narcissism and their
sense of pride in themselves and in
their crimes in shorts given the chance
many killers love to talk about
themselves especially if they have a
captive audience
[Music]
for many ordinary folks the idea of
coming face-to-face with the serial
killer is terrifying but who did someone
who interviewed serial killers on a
regular basis ranked as the worst of the
worst
for starters Lawrence Bittaker in 1978
particular rain Norris at the California
State Prison
they shared a morbid fantasy of
kidnapping and killing teenage girls
after brutally torturing them and while
they did killing five girls between the
ages of 13 and 18 Douglass thought he
was particularly bad because he looked
so ordinary so normal he was the sort of
guy that these teenage hitchhikers
wouldn't have thought twice about
getting into a van with unfortunately
for them yet nicknamed his van the
murder Mack Bittaker and Norris made
audio recordings as they tortured the
girls and Douglas had the tapes when
Scott Glen was getting ready to play his
fictional counterpart in Silence of the
Lambs and the actor come to his office
he played the tapes and says Glen's
response was emotionally charged John he
said I was against the death penalty but
I didn't know there are people like that
the interview that stood out to Douglas
is one of the most fascinating also has
a Silence of the Lambs connection and it
was the killer who is the inspiration
for Buffalo Bill
Gary Hyde Nick was convicted in 1989
found guilty of holding women who came
to be known as Hyde Nick's house of
horrors as he beat raped tortured and
killed them forcing us surviving
captives to help dismember the dead then
mixing the remains with dog food and
feeding it to his prisoners Douglas has
also talked about the one truly
unnerving thing that all interviews have
in common the environment he said going
into prisons the doors clanging behind
you the noise level in the prisons it's
just so loud I don't trust the inmates
at times I don't even trust Corrections
[Music]
as Douglas collected more information he
and his colleagues began compiling it
into a centralized database called ViCAP
or the violence Criminal Apprehension
program and it's worth a quick aside to
mention two of those colleagues Douglas
wasn't working alone yet upon our in FBI
agent Robert Ressler Ressler joined the
FBI in 1970 and transferred to the BSU
when it was formed he's the one who
coined the term serial killer Douglas
also worked with a forensic nurse named
a Norbert Burgas who started out working
with the victims of sexual abuse and did
some of the first formalized studies of
rape cases in Boston the FBI director at
the time William Webster's saw it as
valuable information that his agents
needed to be trained in and later
Burgess was brought on board to help
translate what Douglas and Ressler were
learning into academic terms that could
be applied to other cases together with
a small team who Burgas remembers is not
getting much resistance from the
powers-that-be simply because it wasn't
seen as important at the time
Douglas began to try to make sense of
what they were learning from the
criminals that they were interviewing
and patterns began to emerge the first
was the idea that a killer could be
either organized or disorganized
essentially meaning they either plans
their crimes or they did not from there
they developed a method of looking for
patterns within the crimes signatures
specific to certain killers that could
be used to tie murders together and
behaviors that hinted at motivation as
he often says if you want to understand
the artist look at his art Douglass
determines that at the heart of serial
criminals of almost any kind of three
words manipulation domination control
why are these driving factors there well
according to Douglas his interviews
uncovered a pattern now familiar to
anyone who watches crime shows the
behavior of predators was formed in
childhood when he said they all grew up
without forming trusting bonds with
other human beings during their
formative years he developed ideas
regarding the questions of nature versus
nurture to our serial killers born or
are they made he argued while no one who
does not have certain inborn tendencies
towards impulsivity anger and or
sadistic perversion is going to evolve
into a predator because of bad
upbringing there is no doubt in my mind
that those
possessing such inborn tendencies can be
pushed along the path to predation by
negative influences as they grow up and
mature many of these ideas are embodied
in one of the most notorious serial
killers that Douglass ever interviewed
when Douglass talked to Ed Kemper he was
in jail for killing his mother her
friend and six college students
Kember gave a full confession and showed
police where to find the bodies despite
the fact that he was well known to those
police some called him big Ed's and he
liked to hang out and drink with him at
a local bar as Douglas talked to him he
found the roots of his crimes went back
into childhood he had a terrible
relationship with his abusive mother and
after being relentlessly bullied and
abused by his grandparents he killed
them both when he was just 15 his
history of violence it went back even
further to when a ten-year-old kemper
killed the family's cat Kemper embodied
something Douglas found in all serial
predators that he interviewed and he
described it as an internal conflict
where feelings of self-importance
grandiosity and superiority were
constantly at war with feelings of
inadequacy and inferiority hadn't they
childhood full of abuse and it's a
recipe for a killer and much of the time
the signs are there from childhood
Douglas described another pattern he saw
called the homicidal triad its cruelty
to animals starting fires and bedwetting
a group of behaviors that can indicate
something is deeply wrong none of it he
was careful to stress excused any of
their actions in the end they did what
they did of their own free will
Douglas spends almost his entire career
getting inside the heads of serial
offenders who have acted on some of
their deepest darkest desires
fantasies so horrible they would have
made the devil blush and did these
people get into his head in return
absolutely
in 1983 he added to Seattle to consult
on the Green River murder case he said
goodbye to his wife at their home then
on a hunt she headed to the school where
she was teaching and said goodbye again
by the time he hit Seattle he had a
raging headache and told the other
agents he was working with that he
thought he was getting the flu that was
Tuesday night and he told them that he
was taking time off until Friday the
week went by Friday came along and no
one had heard from him they kicked open
his door Do Not Disturb sign and all and
found him he had collapsed and spent
three days on the floor in a coma the
official diagnosis was viral and colitis
and post-traumatic stress disorder he
spent five months in rehab and was told
that something needed to change and did
it well that's debatable
Douglas oversaw an average of a thousand
cases each and every year up until his
retirement in 1995 post retirements he
continued to write about the cases he
studied give lectures and work on
high-profile cases like the John Bennett
Ramsey case and the West Memphis Three
the nightmares were worse when he was
young part of that might be because of
his belief that the night is the best
time for quiet introspection for going
over the details of cases crime scenes
and interviews of dissecting everything
for every last bit of information it was
hard for him to turn off what he swore
and heard during the day and while it's
a vital part of law enforcement to
become desensitized certain sights and
sounds Douglass couldn't allow himself
to do that not when he was trying to
learn what made them do the things that
they had done what I do I felt like I
could not put up any kind of wall
Douglas said to really understand and
interpret a crime you have to walk in
the shoes of the offender as well as the
victim and that means visualizing
everything so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do hit that thumbs up button below and
do not forget to subscribe we got brand
new videos just like this four times per
week also if you want to support us in
our mission to make those videos please
do check out Monday comm there is a
to them below and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]
you